I have a riddle to solve and you might
be able to help me solve it you see I
think that 2024 might represent an
inflection point for the flow Arts as
the community transitions out of one
generation of artists and into another
but why do I believe that and what might
be in store for the future let's find
out
together D here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and in this video I'm
going to outline why I think there's
cause for both concern and hope for the
future of the flow Arts but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys pyrro Tera light toys
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like Yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca beckon thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission in the past week I've
been assembling several threads that
have been drifting through my head for
weeks if not months now and that's led
me to realize that I have some questions
that I don't know if I have the answers
to and I'd love it if some of you could
help me answer them but first we need to
understand how I got to that point why
do I think that 2024 is an inflection
year and what does that mean for the
future let me walk you through how I got
here and is going to start off just like
my own flow Journey did way back in 2006
with Burning Man in 2024 for the first
time in more than a decade The Burning
Man Arts Festival failed to sell out of
tickets it is facing a financial
shortfall so extreme that it is seeking
$20 million in support to balance its
year-end books and burning man wasn't
the only event to struggle with
attendance this year but many others had
it much worse festivals like Allin
Firefly Lucidity and Sonic Bloom are
among the huge list of events that did
not happen in 2024 and that's not to
even include the events that said 2024
would be their last year and these
events are important to the flow Arts
Community or at least the version of it
that we've had for the past decade and a
half these music and art festivals are
where many people are first introduced
to a prop they have a huge role in
people discovering the flowart in the
first place they also share many traits
in common with the fire and flow
festivals that cater more specifically
to the flow community and which have
been on the steady decline for more than
a decade now companies in the flow Arts
are pretty notorious for their lack of
transparency and operational opacity but
I will say that in an exchange with the
manager of one of the larger flow events
here in the United States last week I
was told that their attendance has not
returned to pre-co levels and even those
levels were not exactly what you'd call
sustainable and there's also online
engagement for 10 years now I've kept
track of traffic to the biggest channels
that produce content related to flow
Arts juggling circus fire spinning and
related topics and the past two years
have seen a pretty steep decline across
the board in their traffic I've
certainly seen this on my own channel I
used to regularly top a thousand views
in the first 24 hours for many of my
videos now if that's going to happen at
all it can take up to a week to get
there and I've heard anecdotal evidence
from other flow artists on social media
that they're also seeing a tra decline
on their content posted to Tik Tok
Instagram and Facebook this all seems
pretty bad right the events that Channel
people into the flow Arts are
experiencing a massive decline in
interest and online engagement also
reveals a similar decline that sounds
like a lot of data points suggesting
that the flow Arts might be in trouble
so what if I told you that every prop
manufacturer I've talked to in the past
2 years has told me that 2023 was one of
if not their best year of sales ever
what how does that make sense I've been
trying to resolve this Paradox in my
head now for a while and I think in the
end that it might not be a paradox at
all it's the product of two different
Trends converging and telling me that
there's a segment of the flowarts world
that I have a very limited visibility on
and that we're at a point where the
tastes of one generation are no longer
driving this community and it's time to
learn more about the tastes of another
to explain why I want to revisit Burning
Man lucidity Sonic Bloom and the other
events that were canceled this past year
because many of them have something very
important in common these are all
festivals that are marketed under the
label transformational events that is
events in which attendance centers not
around just getting to hear great music
or seeing cool art but about having
life-changing and impactful experiences
and I think we can see a mirror to this
process in the fire and flow Festival
world too flow festivals similarly Place
themselves into the mold of
transformational events in licitly if
not explicitly many if not most include
eye-catching art that makes for
instagrammable backgrounds and
programming built around ritual and
ceremony how many posts have you seen
online from people returning from flow
or fire festivals gushing about how
life-changing or impactful they were so
it doesn't seem shocking to me that as
bigger events catering to these
demographic demands see a decline in
attendance we will see a similar decline
in the smaller and more Niche ones too
and here's the kicker the use of the
label transformational event was a means
of marketing events specifically towards
Millennials Millennials are legendary
for having consumption habits centered
around purchasing experiences in
contrast to their parents habits around
consuming Goods transformational events
whether they be burning man or fire
festivals very deliberately Center their
brand and marketing around selling those
experiences and honestly I think we can
follow a similar thread with the social
media component too social media grew
rapidly with Millennials coming age and
it was their demand to share the
experiences they were purchasing in
online spaces that fueled the rapid
growth and later ubiquity of everything
from YouTube to Facebook and Instagram
and likewise we've seen a leveling off
of Engagement with social media in the
past few years whether it's because of
bad press relating to its impact on
psychological Health distrust of the
algorithm or even just the need for some
new novelty by and large social media
companies have struggled to maintain the
heights of Engagement that they saw
during the pandemic and to be perfectly
clear I am not saying these Trends are
good or bad I'm merely pointing out that
they are Trends and every trend has its
externalities both positive and negative
so I think what we're witnessing with
the decline of online engagement and
attendance to transformational events is
also the decline in influence of
Millennials many are now nearing middle
age and their habits are changing as a
result and as Millennials decline in
influence gen Z and gen Alpha are just
about to reach the height of their
influence on pop culture just as
Millennials took over from Generation X
a decade and a half ago so if gen Z and
genen Alpha are still spending props and
the evidence from prop sales certainly
suggests that they are how exactly are
they discovering them and how are they
creating communities for them because
they're not doing it at festivals or
online are people switching back to
community- based engagement on a local
level rather than online engagement or
Community centered around bigger events
it could be from what I saw last year in
Seattle they have a thriving community
that is both really well organized as
well as highly visible I've also heard
good things about Chicago but haven't
gotten to see it firsthand myself that
said these cities kind of seem to be the
exception rather than the rule from what
I can gather I don't hear about that
many other cities that have scenes that
are quite so well organized though this
may also be a result of the limits of my
own experiences there's also a really
intriguing albeit kind of sad study
related to the decline in festivals that
dovet tales with this too a survey
released in the UK asked young people
why they did not attend music festivals
in the past year and the number one
response was that they didn't think that
they had a friend to go with that
probably also doesn't bode well for
small local communities either online
consumption habits seem to be changing
too there's been strong growth in Walled
sharing apps like Discord that create
private spaces for people to share
things in to say nothing of the growth
in messaging apps for keeping private
conversations as well but likewise I
think this may be a bit of a red herring
in the past year I've joined a couple
Discord servers centering around flow
arts or related pastimes and what I've
found is that overall the actual traffic
on them related to discussing or sharing
things related to using props is quite
low in most cases they just wind up
being another place where people share
the odd details of the day casually so
how are jenz flow artists engaging with
the art I have no idea and that's kind
of exciting exciting because it means
that there's a riddle to be solved and
that dear viewer is where you come in
according to my YouTube analytics 15% of
you out there are under the age of 25
and I really want to hear from you where
did you first learn about the flow Arts
do you practice alone or do you have
friends that you meet up with how did
you find those friends do you attend
events Like Music Arts or flow festivals
if so which ones and if not why not and
what is it about the flow Arts that
speak to you what is is it that draws
you toward learning how to spin dance or
perform with a prop leave me some
comments because I am dying to learn
also a quick note to those of you out
there that run events sell props or
otherwise have businesses that thrive on
the participation of flow artists those
comments are going to be a huge resource
be sure to give them a read as well I
don't think the flow Arts are going
anywhere but I am noticing a shift one
that I think shows that in the next few
years this community is going to look
very different from the one that came up
in and that's okay everything has a life
cycle and I appreciate the experiences
that I had over the course of the past
decade and a half for what they were but
I think it's also clear that it's time
for a change because the ways we used to
build community don't seem to be working
for the Next Generation coming in and I
think we should approach that with
curiosity and find out what they connect
with what they want and work to find
ways that we can all feel satisfied by
engaging in this art did you get
anything out of this video video if so
please leave this video a like a comment
share it and subscribe to the channel I
make lots of videos on PO spinning and
flow arts and subscribing will ensure
that you see my new videos right when
they drop and it helps the channel
[Music]
grow this video would not have been
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a huge shout out to my flow patrons
who are listed on screen now thank you
all so much you're Rock and if you enjoy
the content that I create but you're not
a supporter yet that's a problem that is
easily remedied sign up for my patreon
over at
patreon.com drexfactor poo and not only
will you get access to awesome rewards
like early access to my content or
exclusive lessons but you'll also be
supporting me in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you're hungry for more
video essays on the flow Arts Community
here's one that I did on the decline of
the flow festivals and what I think
caused it certainly I have additional
thoughts on the topic that I mentioned
in this video but that video also
features much more data and a much more
comprehensive and detailed approach to
the problem I'll link to that video up
here on screen and and down in the
description thank you so much for
watching make sure you get out and flow
yourself today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace